what I want to do with this video is
give ourselves some practice and
hopefully some intuition on multiplying
a scalar times a vector now what am I
talking about when I say multiplying a
scalar times a vector well let me set up
a little two-dimensional vector here so
let's say I have the vector W and let me
give it an X component let's say it's X
component is 1 and it's Y component is
let's say it's 2 and I could draw it if
I like actually that's a good idea it's
always nice to be able to visualize
these things let me get some coordinate
get a coordinate axis here so that's my
x axis that is my Y axis and so if I
were to draw this vector in kind of
standard form I would put its initial
point at the origin and then its
terminal point would be at the point 1
comma 2 so its x-coordinate is 1 its
y-coordinate is going to be 2 so 1 2
this vector is going to look like is
going to the initial point is right here
it's terminal point is going to be right
over there the vector in standard
graphing it in standard form or
visualize it in standard form would look
like that now of course I could have the
same vector and I could shift it around
as long as I have the same length of the
arrow and it's pointing in the same
direction but if you know no one tells
you otherwise it's nice to just put its
initial point at the origin now let's
multiply it by a scalar now what do we
mean by a scalar well a vector is
something that has a magnitude and a
direction a scalar is just something
that has a magnitude you could think of
just the numbers that you started
learning when you were 4 years old that
those are those are scalars so for
example we can think about what is what
is 3 times W going to be 3 times W 3 is
a scalar W is a vector now the
convention we use for multiplying a
scalar times a vector is you just
multiply each of the components times
that scalar so this is going to be equal
to this is so R we have a 1 and a 2 and
we're going to multiply each of those
time's the 3 3 times 1 and then 3 times
2 and so this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to 3 times 1
is 3
3 times 2 is 6 and so we see the
resulting vector 3 we could call this
vector 3w or it's going to have an X
component of 3 and a Y component of 6 so
if I were to draw it in standard form
here X component 1 2 3 and then Y
component 2 3 4 5 and 6 and so it's
going to look like this
let me see if I can draw it reasonably
it's going to look like this and
obviously I'm hand drawing it so it's
not going to be exactly right but it's
going to look like that so this is the
vector 3 times W now notice what
happened when I multiplied it by the
scalar the direction didn't change but
the magnitude did and you see what the
magnitude changed by it changed it
increased by a factor of 3 this was our
the length of my blue arrow now is 3
times the length of my magenta arrow
let's do another example I'll use the
same vector W since we already have it
set up let's multiply it times a
negative scalar so let's say let's see
what happens if I multiply negative 2 x
times W and like always I encourage you
to pause the video and think about what
this would be and even if you have the
time graph it out well we would multiply
each of our components by negative 2 so
it would be equal to negative 2 times 1
it would be the X component and the y
component would be negative 2 times 2
and so this is going to be equal to the
vector negative 2 comma negative 4
well let's plot that so the X component
is negative 2 so it's negative 1
negative 2 and then the Y component
negative 1 2 3 I'm going a little bit
off of my axis 4 so that would be
negative 4 there that's negative 2 so
it's going to look something like the
this it's going to look something like
something like that so that right over
there is a vector negative 2w now let's
think about what just happened well we
because we had the negative year it
essentially flipped the direction by 180
degrees it's going in the opposite
direction but one way to think about you
could they kind of would still sit on
the same line so the negative just
flipped its direction if this if you if
you consider whatever direction this was
the the magenta vector W is going it's
not going to go in the opposite
direction and then it also scaled it up
by two this is twice as long has twice
the magnitude of our original vector and
it's going in the opposite direction
because of the negative sign so
hopefully this gives you a little bit of
intuition of what it means to scale a
vector I mean literally the word scalar
has the has the let me write it down ski
scaler these are sets a scalar that's a
scalar it has the word scale in it it's
literally just scaling the vector it is
changing its magnitude it might flip it
around because of a negative sign but
it's essentially changing its magnitude
scaling it up or down or flipping it
around with a negative sign